is it possible to have missed
your opportunity to be sealed
well yes of course of course it is possible
that's why it's so dangerous to play with jesus
it's dangerous you know people they
receive convictions from god all the time
they know it but they resist it they won't come
to church they won't study they want they feel
the conviction they know that they ought to make
this change make that they don't do it and the
time comes where they have lost all opportunity to
come to christ yes you can lose the opportunity to
be sealed and to be sure about jesus christ you
can lose that opportunity but god gives us long
opportunity many extended he's long suffering
but at some point you can lose it yes you can
and you lose spiritual things all interests and
not even the holy spirit then can do anything with
you because you're gone you know you look at the
plagues in chapter 16 of revelation god sends the
plague the people still blaspheme him you see what
i'm saying they are so set against him instead of
saying no i'm sorry i'm sorry they blasphemed him
as the plagues for they continue to blaspheme him
they're dead set against him so you
and i well you and i hopefully not
but someone can come to the place where he
or she has missed that final opportunity
to be right with christ it's a tragedy
because you cannot reverse that
the people running around every
day playing with eternal life
my thinking i have tomorrow i have the
day after i have next week i have 2022.
you don't you have today today all right question
let me say someone sent me a question on twitter
is it okay to take a small glass of wine i
just smiled we deal with probation now you see
the things that overthrow most people are not
big they're small the kingdom of heaven is like a
mustard seed but the kingdom of satan is also like
the mustard seed you take that one little seed
into you you can destroy your entire life so so
i wrote back and said a little glass of wine okay
all adam did was to take a little glass of fruit
that's all he did and look what happened to the
world and so the person wrote back and said
oh man well i need to avoid it i said yes
and so the little things we ought to watch the
big things they're so obvious the little things
we ought to watch very closely because adam and
eve fell on what we may regard as a little thing
so in this trouble style you have to
watch the little things in our lives
you